Ennio Morricone revisité par cathyza ça
donne ça
[Musique]
un son envoûtant apparemment sorti de
l'invisible avec des notes obtenues en
pinçant ou en caressant du vide enfin
pas tout à fait le tiramide est un
appareil transformant les vibrations des
champs électromagnétiques en ondes
ressemble à une voix il est aussi
comparable à un instrument à corde je
suis violoniste et aussi chanteuse et
quand j'ai découvert le terrain
cet instrument
croise a su partager avec les élèves
venus découvrir un univers fascinant qui
met de l'ambiance
[Musique]
ambre c'est laisser prendre jeu encore
un peu ému après sa prestation
on entend un bruit et que
c'était impressionnant
[Musique]
autre découverte pour les scolaires le
Crystal Bachy un métal à friction
un étrange instrument aux allures
d'oxylophones équipées de tubes et
amplificateurs soniques aux lignes
futuristes faisant penser à un vaisseau
spatial
tu penses tu prends la note ici tu la
pinces
[Musique]
après quelques instants de pratique
Stanislas est sous le charme en fait
c'est
un peu spécial instrument
comme ça et puis un instrument comme ça
multi instrumentiste loup-garou Navigo
gré des notes de musique depuis son
enfance toujours en quête d'originalité
il a fondu pour ce drôle de clavier
fragile et puissant à la fois je
trouvais que c'était un instrument qui
me rappelait la nature en fait qui me
rappelait les sons de la nature comme
une baleine comme le vent comme voilà
quelque chose de très mystique
[Musique]
c'est des archers de verre qu'on joue
avec les doigts mouillés le son est
amplifié il y a des amplificateurs
devant un amplificateur basse médium
aigu
des sons captivants surprenants
immédiatement le spectateur dans des
ambiances fantastiques
[Musique]